BEAT THIS THING UNTIL WE GET A
VACCINE AND THAT’S PROBABLY
STILL 18 MONTHS AWAY NOW.
>> Neil: THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
I WANT TO BRING SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM INTO ALL OF THIS.
SENATOR, WHAT IS YOUR SENSE
YOU’RE GETTING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE AND FROM ANY OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES ABOUT HOW THIS IS
SORTING OUT OR NOT SORTING OUT?
>> GO BIG, THE BOTTOM LINE IS,
I’VE BEEN ON THE HILL ALL DAY, I
HAVEN’T SEEN THIS KIND OF SPIRIT
SINCE 9/11, EVERYBODY’S LOOKING
AT EACH OTHER AS AN ALLY, NOT A
FOE.
PEOPLE IN AMERICA, YOU BEGIN TO
SEE THE BEST OF THE COUNTRY, THE
YOUNG LADY ON THE SHOW BEFORE,
DELIVERING FOOD TO ELDERLY
PEOPLE, ALLOWING SENIORS TO SHOP
AHEAD OF EVERYBODY ELSE IN
GROCERY STORES.
IT’S GOING TO TAKE THAT KIND OF
SPIRIT TO DEFEAT THIS BUT HERE’S
THE PROBLEM, 80% OF THE
WORKFORCE IS GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY THE CONTAINMENT
POLICY.
THE MONEY WE’RE SPENDING TO DEAL
WITH HEALTH CARE IS GOING TO
PALE INTO COMPARISON WITH THE
MONEY WE SPEND TO STABILIZE THE
ECONOMY.
IF YOU’VE BEEN LAID OFF TODAY IN
SOUTH CAROLINA FROM A BAR OR
RESTAURANT OR HOTEL, I’M LOOKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE WAGE
REPLACEMENT, THAT WE REPLACE
YOUR INCOME IS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
SO THAT YOU DON’T HAVE YOUR LIFE
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN, THAT’S THE
NUMBER ONE GOAL OF PHASE THREE
FOR ME.
>> Neil: SENATOR, OBVIOUSLY
MONEY IN PEOPLE’S HANDS IS A
GOOD THING ESPECIALLY FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT BUT IS IT
YOUR SENSE THAT THE PROBLEM HERE
IS THE VIRUS ITSELF AND THAT
PEOPLE ARE HUNKERED DOWN IN
THEIR HOMES AFRAID TO GO OUT
BECAUSE OF THAT -- THEY MIGHT
USE THAT BUT IT WON’T HAVE THE
DESIRED EFFECT ON THE ECONOMY,
IS THAT EVEN PART OF THE
RATIONALE HERE?
>> IT’S MY RATIONALE, I WANT TO
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY BUT IT’S
IMPOSSIBLE TO STIMULATE IT WHEN
IT’S LOCKED DOWN.
IF I GAVE YOU YOUR PAYCHECK,
THAT WILL BE ENOUGH TO GET YOU
THROUGH UNTIL WE CAN FIND A WAY
TO FULLY DEAL WITH THE VIRUS.
YOUR PAYCHECK PLUS $1,000
DOESN’T DO YOU ANY GOOD.
I WANT YOU TO GAVE YOUR PAYCHECK
IS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
>> Neil: IF THIS DRAGS ON A
WHILE, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
FROZEN IN PLACE REGARDLESS OF
WHAT STIMULUS IS COMING THEIR
WAY.
>> YOU CAN’T STIMULATE IT.
WE ARE BUYING CONTAINMENT,
EVERYTHING I’VE JUST TALKED TO
YOU ABOUT IS THE PRICE OF
CONTAINMENT, SHUTTING EVERY BAR
AND RESTAURANT DOWN IN
SOUTH CAROLINA IS THE COST OF
CONTAINMENT.
WE EITHER PAY NOW AS A COUNTRY
OR WE PAY LATER AND WHAT WE DO